[Music]
king charles traveled to northern
ireland this morning with camilla the
new queen consort that's the official
term for it she's been by his side
throughout the morning period for queen
elizabeth
playing a role that many people in that
country would have denied her in the
past roxanna saberi is at windsor guild
hall for us outside london with more on
the public acceptance of the queen
consort roxanna good morning
good morning for years camilla was one
of the most controversial figures
surrounding the royal family but since
she and charles got married here back in
2005 her image has gradually improved
and now for many brits that controversy
has been laid to rest
the united kingdom is getting more than
just a new king it's also getting a new
queen queen consort that is
i know
she will bring to the demands of her new
role the steadfast devotion to duty on
which i have come to rely so much julian
payne was the couple's communications
secretary for six years what role do you
think camilla will play for the king
she's a balancing act what that means is
she's got a real sense of what normality
is and and how to translate that and
bring that into this quite rarefied
atmosphere
it's a remarkable rise for a woman who
was once one of the most derided figures
in britain she was public enemy number
one here
incredibly unpopular media coverage she
had here 27 years ago camilla
parker-bowles was considered the other
woman princess diana blamed for the
breakup of her marriage there were three
of us in this marriage so it was a bit
crowded
the bbc later apologized for the way
that now infamous 1995 interview was
obtained but diana's words still stung
charles was said to have been smitten as
soon as he met camilla in the 1970s
they each married others but remained
close
later both couples famously divorced and
with diana's death in 1997
camilla's popularity plummeted even more
gradually charles and camilla stepped
back out in public
did he get down on one knee to propose
by the time they married in 2005
thousands of royal fans lined the
streets of windsor
in pop culture and to much of the public
camilla's image as the maligned mistress
remained what we both want and what we
can actually do are not the same thing
but recent polls suggest she's slowly
warming hearts
people have started to see the person
behind the headlines she was firmly of
the view that you should meet me and you
should judge me on how you find me and
on the work that i do camilla has
championed her own causes like
supporting victims of domestic abuse how
many more women must be harassed
raped or murdered it also helped that
earlier this year queen elizabeth
announced that the duchess of cornwall
should one day take the title of queen
consort
it was unbelievably brilliant move by
the queen to do that just tidying up all
the loose ends before she went and so
this weekend outside buckingham palace
some people told us their views on the
queen consort are evolving i think
she'll be amazing she will be his rock
like
prince philip was the queen's rock
in a vogue uk article earlier this year
camilla said the decades of public
scrutiny have not been easy but that
she's tried to get on with life the 75
year old will now get on as queen
consort her main role to support her
husband the king
for cbs mornings roxanna saberi windsor